appears some changes are coming to the
embattled Clark County School Board
three incumbents running but only one
may survive Mary Jane beliesza live this
afternoon at District headquarters with
the details Mary Jane
a change to the board is on the way for
the Clark County School District as
voters got a chance to set the course
for the country's largest fifth largest
school district on Tuesday there are
three board seats up for grabs and
District D president Irene Cepeda is
running against Brenda Zamora Cepeda was
elected to the board in 2018 and took
over as president in early 2022 after
serving as vice president meanwhile in
District F trustee Danielle Ford is
running against Irene Bustamante Adams
trustee Linda Cavazos and former Eureka
County school superintendent Greg weeman
are competing for the district G seat
this election follows years of turmoil
as the school district has also spent
thousands of dollars for training and
Retreat to try to get along on taxpayers
dime despite the training fighting at
school board meetings and social media
continued so far unofficial results show
sapita and Ford may be losing their seat
as Cavazos may be keeping hers School
races are nonpartisan so any candidate
winning a majority of the vote will win
election to the board I reached out to
candidates today I was able to speak
with Irene Cepeda and Greg weeman
I think at the end of the day we trust
what the voters you know what the voters
say and uh that's you know that's that's
what we do as a democracy we we vote and
we change leadership or we need to um
according to the voters and I'm at peace
with that I'm what a relief I you know
it hurts a little uh you know you don't
like to lose any contest you're in if
you're a competitor
but at the same time it's uh to me it
was going to be an overwhelming
responsibility we have a lot of work
that needs to be done
the reminder these are unofficial
election results as all ballots are
still being counted and the remaining
trustees and candidates have not yet
responded to me at the time of this
report any new responses will be updated
online and on air reporting from CCSD
headquarters on Saharan Decatur Mary
Jane beliesa 8 News Now